these are probably the most popular
categories we got lesbian babysitter big
dick what are you crazy
please don't say it like that you've
never watched porn by yourself no no we
have never watched porn together that's
about to change though it would seem I'm
gonna do that koi thing right I pretend
like I don't know any website no he does
no yeah yes you have a particular one I
don't what yeah I do
oh okay so immediately the first thing
you notice with these sites is like the
advertisements are like certainly
enabled right when you go to the home
page there's an advertisement for juicy
boys I was gonna pick one but it sent
teen and I don't want to support that oh
oh oh he's not gay but they're not
really teenagers not even close
do I want to know what gaping is I think
I know what it is we've got Indian let's
just watch this thing oh no I hate
fisting oh I do like the body shop ones
okay and then the body shops whenever
you need an oil change oh this is cute
it's like a little story I don't think
anything about this is tube oh my god
they're auditioning for a job but there
is no job so now this is the audition he
certainly audition like if you're
auditioning for a movie you'd say the
lines right Cayenne Ali gets by Tupac's
you think those are fake
those are definitely fake is number one
and number two they're very different
sizes different shapes it's rather long
I'm not gonna hang out babe you're fine
okay yeah you know be funny as if she
just was like backed up and like slam to
the dicks again I just want like fast
forward to getting the big one always
wants to fast forward see this is where
most guys would skip Wow she's
pretending to be very into it
you think she's pretending yes
[Laughter]
she's been very dramatic ya see she's
making so much noise ssin feels it looks
impossible to me oh she just slapped his
date
she slapped it alright this amazing orgy
is 56 minutes there's gotta be something
there'll be something in that for you
guys love to come on girls faces I guess
I don't know it's not like I go around
isn't on people's faces maybe you had
some insight into the male psyche don't
they do party games first like what why
are they oh this is it this is the party
game okay
here we go that's okay so that's what DP
means I'm sure there are realistic horns
out there but like 90% of that what we
just watch now like the girls always
sound like they're having orgasms and
like what the guy is doing is not really
causing an orgasm and I think that's
almost the worst part I mean that's why
they make porn because it's stuff that
you don't get in your everyday life
that's the fantasies that you yeah
exactly it's pretty demoralizing
sometimes because um ya know I'm just
like what am I doing wrong here but yeah
just watching it together a little more
I'd been normal now he knows that I'm
like who wants to see a close-up of like
just like the insertion like that are
like coming out of places that they
shouldn't be yeah so would you say that
you at least have a appreciation or like
a respect for what they do
100% oh yeah I think that it's great
that porn exists I don't think I could
ever sit down and seriously be like hey
let's do this together as foreplay
that's just the center is something that
I feel like I don't
wander need uh just be with you forever
right it's just getting weird
[Music]
oh the couches all the couches
[Music]